>>Reto: Good afternoon and welcome again to
the Friday review of apps.
My name is Reto Meier.
And joining me in the studio I have with me
Trevor Jones.
>>Trevor: Hi there everyone.
>>Reto: And via the miracle of modern technology
joining us from his new abode in New York
City, we have Romain Yurik.
>>Romain: Hello everyone.
>>Reto: Hey Romain.
Thank you for joining us in your flickery
self.
So we're going to take a look at a few apps
today.
And while Ian tries to figure out what the
flickering is about.
We may start off by having a look at Samo
Color.
So we're also going to look at GPS.
Test a couple of notes apps.
And some exercise apps as well . Run Double.
So we've got quite an interesting and eclectic
collection for you today.
So shall we get started.
>>Trevor: Sure, Let's, go ahead.
>>Reto: Let's have a look at Samo Color.
So we're going to fire this up on the phone
over here.
So, I'll wait 'til Ian gets a chance.
Excellent.
Oops, I had that space.
Alright.
Perfect.
So here we go.
So Samo Color by Code Carpet.
Tap three times to buy.
I wonder what my alternatives are.
So I can see an arrow here so I'm gonna slide
across.
And I can see a number of different options
here.
Not entirely sure what they are.
OK.
So they're locked.
Alright.
So we'll go here and click.
Oh, OK.
Interesting.
So this is, in case it wasn't obvious, this
is an app which is targeted towards children.
>>Trevor: Hence the tap three times to buy.
>>Reto: [laughs] Indeed.
Mostly children who can't read.
>>Trevor: Actually, it's not a bad idea.
'Cause a lot of times people, you know we
hear from people who write apps or directed
towards apps who are targeted towards children
is that there's these "buy" buttons and children
just go and hit on them accidentally.
So I like that you have, like, kids are just
going to go and mash on the screen.
So anything to go and prevent them from accidentally
buying is probably a good thing.
>>Reto: Probably a good thing.
Absolutely.
Although I wonder, I wonder if you wanna go
a step further and actually hide that behind
a menu option or something like that.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
It's probably a good idea to actually go all
the way to turn on the pin lock and mark it.
But.
>>Reto: Yeah.
That's a very good point.
But still it's a good point you make.
So the idea here is that you can color in
the little guy on screen.
Using the colors at our disposal.
Let's see, give him green ears.
Blue.
>>Trevor: There are actually more colors.
>>Reto: There are more colors?
Oh, look at that.
I can swipe to get more colors.
>>Trevor: Took me a moment to figure that
out.
>>Reto: Interesting.
>>Trevor: I mean it is a little widget down
there to go and show you more pages.
>>Reto: That's true.
>>Trevor: But amongst all the noise of all
the colors, it's actually really easy to miss.
>>Reto: It didn't occur to me that the pager
was resp-- was talking about the colors themselves.
That's interesting.
So, OK, so what I would say is, in a particular
for something just color in here.
>>Trevor: There's also a menu too, by the
way.
>>Reto: I saw it does have a menu.
>>Trevor: No, not that menu.
>>Reto: Ah.
>>Trevor: See the little black thing with
eyes.
>>Reto: Ooooh.
It's a menu.
That's interesting.
So two points here.
First is, let me just, scroll up slightly.
Menu button of shame.
Because it's there but doesn't do anything.
>>Trevor: Especially, especially because there
isn't anything, there's really no reason to
have that.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So that's the big hate we have for the menu
button being there, is if it actually doesn't
do anything.
>>Trevor: Even if it still does something,
you shouldn't have it anymore.
>>Reto: That's true.
That's true.
>>Trevor: There is no excuse for having a
menu button at this point.
>>Reto: Yeah, I think we've got, I think we've
moved on far enough now.
With Jellybean coming out.
>>Trevor: With Jellybean now, yes, now our
second release where the menu button.
Well, if you can't.
There you go.
Third release where the menu button is just
deprecated.
So yeah, at this point we really shouldn't
be seeing that anymore.
>>Reto: Exactly, so that would be step one
is remove that menu button.
Now, having the little eyes, that's interesting.
So, now, I see, you actually drag it.
>>Trevor: You can click as well.
>>Reto: Click-tug doesn't seem to be working
100 percent of the time.
So that's a bit fade back.
But.
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Reto: It also works.
The dragging is quite nice.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
The other thing that confused me to.
Now, that back button, what would, would you
think that's "back"?
>>Reto: Ah, that's a good question.
It's just above the other back button.
I would probably think undo.
>>Trevor: It is undo.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Trevor: But it took me a while.
I was like, what's gonna happen if I push
this button?
>>Reto: Yeah, definitely.
Anything which looks like a back button I
think you're kind of taking your usability
into your own hands here.
'Cause you suddenly go, oooh, is this gonna
exit?
Now clearly kids aren't gonna think that.
They're probably also not gonna think "undo."
>>Trevor: Well, they might think the regular
back button thing is "undo".
>>Reto: Oh.
That's a good point.
Particularly once you've made it ambiguous
here that maybe "back" means "undo".
You probably wanna simplify that.
So I don't think this is discoverable at all.
It would never have occurred to me to press
the googly eyes.
Now, in fairness a six year old probably would
think to hit pretty much everything on the
screen.
So that would help.
But, there's an awful lot--
>>Trevor: let me ask if there's multi level
undo.
But it's a children's app, so we'll give them
a pass on that.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Exactly.
That would be nice.
And particularly like, so once you hit undo
having that stay onscreen so that you can
do multilevel undo would be nice.
But maybe, maybe have these as, as an action
bar along the top might be interesting.
I guess you wanna keep the screen clutter
down.
You don't want to have people accidentally
pressing buttons.
So having it hidden in a way is useful, but.
>>Trevor: Again, there is the argument that
kids are going to mash everything on the screen.
So I can sort of see the argument for hiding
it.
But I think the discoverability could really
be improved.
>>Reto: Yeah.
What do you think Romain?
Do you have a, from a usability perspective,
an idea here of how you can maybe make this
more or less obvious?
>>Romain: Yeah, I mean, I think the first
thing is that, asking kids to discover slidy
things, like sliding drawers, that's, I think
that's asking a little too much.
You know in general we recommend using gestures
to uncover things.
Sliding drawers, I personally am kind of against.
But you know, using gestures is normally ok.
Like paging between screens and things like
that.
But for kids, you know kids kind of, they
understand you know, simple gestures.
Like sliding.
But it has to be really really really obvious.
And I don't think it's obvious in this case.
What I'd probably do instead is really just
put it on screen.
And for thinks like "back".
For things like navigating to other pieces
of art, it's actually like right now, once
you're in a drawing, there's no real way to
get to other drawings.
So for that you may wanna use gestures.
Like maybe slide left to kind of go back to
the top level screen.
But you know, sliding up a thing to reveal
actions or even at the very bottom something
as simple as using a view pager to slide between
different colors.
Even that may be a little too unobvious.
So in that case maybe just have left and right
buttons.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Romain: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: Well there's already two people
that didn't notice you could slide the colors.
So.
>>Reto: Yeah.
[laughs] 'Cause that's, actually that gesture
you described is what I assumed the pager
was for.
If I started swiping left or right it would
take me to a different pictures.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: That's why the visual cue wasn't obvious
to me that it was [inaudible]
>>Romain: I think, just, like in generally
when dealing with kids apps you wanna put
more stuff in a fun, like friendly, like picture
form onscreen.
Rather than rely on gestures too much.
So I think in this case kids may get confused.
Like "Oh, how do I get back to whatever."
And obviously grownups will know that oh,
you press the back button.
It's the android back button.
But kids aren't as, they're not as used to
using the smart phones.
>>Trevor: Hm.
>>Romain: So don't assume that's standard,
kind of android patterns apply.
>>Reto: Yeah, I think that's particularly
through because while it's good that they
put this consistent approach to using the
pager.
And you know I'm quite a fan of having this
indicator to show you what page you're on.
They use it to me, sort of different things
on different pages.
Oops, managed to exit.
Oh if you, that's another tip.
If I exit from a particular drawing.
So if I exit from here when hitting back,
when I reload the app I should go back to
that, to the same place I was.
'cause the chances of someone, particularly
a kid, hitting back and being like "Oh, I've
lost everything."
Is high.
But yeah, so they've used it up here to page
between pictures and once you go in they use
it to page between colors.
Which I think is somewhat confusing.
Particularly 'cause this isn't, is it a proper
pager?
I guess it is.
It's showing a set of different colors each
time.
But yeah.
Having that same visual metaphor meaning two
different things can be a little bit confusing.
>>Romain: Yeah, what you may wanna do is,
when having lots of colors.
In this case there's lots and lots of colors.
There's a lot to choose from.
You may wanna just have like, when you touch
the color it expands up to this larger palette
to choose from.
Or something even like, have them smaller
so that you, a kid can just drag their finger
around like this massive color palette.
The bottom shows them a preview of what color
their finger is on.
Almost like a magnifying glass.
That may make a little more sense than kind
of swiping left and right.
>>Reto: Yeah.
I think so too.
Otherwise it's a, I really like the simplicity
of the app so it's, there's no ambiguity as
to what you need to do.
How it's gonna work.
You get the immediate benefit.
You hit the screen and things start to happen
which is really night.
Pictures are nice.
Cute too.
Otherwise, yeah, I think its' quite a nice
app otherwise.
>>Romain: There's one more thing I wanted
to add.
>>Reto: Please.
>>Romain: there's this one part of the app.
I think it might be the page where the teacher
is standing and looking at a chalkboard.
There's a bunch of different shapes there.
So it's basically free form, you just draw
free form.
>>Trevor: Oh really?
>>Romain: And in that case what I would
>>Reto: Ahhh.
Nice.
>>Romain: So, you should probably support
multitouch there.
Kids love like placing all their fingers all
at once on the screen and dragging them.
>>Trevor: Actually, I'd take that a step further
and try and detect pressure.
>>Romain: Yes.
So there's actually an open source app called
Markers that was recently released by Daniel
Sandler who's on the Android team.
And that shows how to do all sorts of crazy
pressure sensitivity, and as well as multitouch.
>>Trevor: And this is on normal screens.
Just a normal capacitor screen.
You can actually still get some pressure data.
So.
>>Romain: Yeah.
>>Trevor: It's not the same as your wacom
tablet where you have you know, 500 levels
of pressure sensitivity.
But it's good enough to get you an nice UI.
>>Reto: Yeah, that's--
>>Romain: Also you may wanna consider having
a single, just like massive, just like take
over the entire screen.
And just give like kids a playground to just
draw on.
Just free form drawing.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Romain: Completely not like a rectangle
or a circle or shape or anything it just gives
them a giant canvas to draw on.
>>Reto: Yeah absolutely.
I think it more obvious too.
Because it would never occur to me that if
I hit one of the three objects on the right
here that that would mean that I get free
form drawing.
Whereas that would seem like one of the, something
which you would particularly want to be able
to do.
>>Romain: It's locked.
>>Reto: oh it's locked.
Yeah, of course.
Why isn't it working?
Which is another tip as well.
So obviously you've got the icon on the bottom
which says "locked" which to most adults should
be pretty obvious.
But I missed it.
Which is probably more of a reflection on
me than on your app.
But that being said.
>>Trevor: it should probably be, really you
should just cover the entire screen.
So you can't do anything there.
>>Reto: Hm.
Yeah exactly.
I mean you've already got sort of the partial
opacity.
You could make that so you can see through
it a little bit more but cover the entire
screen.
Or when I press it, display a toast or something
saying "This is locked."
You know.
Purchase from the home screen.
Something like that.
'cause again, it's not obvious.
I know that when you first start up the app
you see the instruction to have a purchase.
>>Trevor: yeah, I like that idea.
Like if you tap the lock thing it should fade
out and say "Purchase from home screen" and
the lock should come back.
You know, add some animation, make it, make
it feel alive.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Some, some way to, yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Which is-- [laughs] and you'll notice that
I find the navigation slightly tricky.
But otherwise, yeah.
Otherwise its' definitely a good idea and
it's nicely implemented.
Just to go along further from what Trevor
was saying.
It might be nice to have a little bit more
animation.
A bit more dynanimacism within the app.
Might, have.
>>Trevor: Maybe have some subtle things.
Like maybe this guy here could be maybe tapping
his foot, or.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Trevor: You know.
Something again, make it feel like you're
just not staring at a static image.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Yeah, I think some really subtle animations
could make a really big difference.
Because you know, it will attract your attention.
It'll make your eye focus on different parts
of it.
so it would be quite interesting.
>>Trevor: Or you know, since this is an app
designed for kids you could have you know,
little Easter eggs.
You know like I think going over here, like
the background, if this wasn't locked, if
I tapped on this guy maybe he'd start moving
or a sound should play, right?
Something that would make people, make kids
wanna go and explore a bit.
>>Reto: Hmm.
Absolutely.
And it' s kind of nice that all the discovery
things, like the free form drawing is all
totally, you know you play with the app and
you discover these things.
Which is kind of nice.
But it would also be perhaps useful in terms
of getting people to use the app in the first
place to give some more indication of what
some of those Easter eggs are.
Some of those things that you can do.
Like maybe a tutorial or something at the
beginning which just has you, you know, forces
you through basically the three different
modes.
Here you press the color to draw.
Here you get free form.
And now we give you these worksheets where
you can do what you want to do.
Any other comments?
Trevor?
Romain?
>>Trevor: I think the [inaudible]
>>Romain: I just wanted to say two quick things.
I know we're running behind on some of this.
But two quick things about the market, or
I'm sorry, the Google play listing.
>>Trevor: Ah.
>>Reto: Ah.
So I should pull it up here and see what we
can do.
>>Romain: This is very quick feedback.
But.
>>Reto: OK.
Search for it first.
>>Trevor: You could always scan the barcode
on our screen in here.
>>Reto: I probably could.
But My Apps is probably faster.
Ah.
Where are we here.
There we are.
OK.
>>Romain: You there?
>>Reto: Yep.
>>Romain: So a couple, so two very quick things.
In the feature graphic you have the name of
the app Samo Colors.
The font size is really really small at the
top.
And so one thing to note is that on, in the
play store, on devices, actually on phones,
you're gonna see the feature graphic compressed
to a really small size.
So you're not gonna be able to read that text.
So if you can find some way to bungle the
font size so that it's a little more obvious,
what the name of the app is, that would be
much better.
'cause there are cases where the feature graphic
is used not adjacent to the name of the app.
The second thing was around screen shots.
Your screenshots are actually using the device
frame generator.
I would probably avoid using device frames
in your screen shots themselves.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Basically too small.
>>Romain: Yeah, because when you open it up
on a phone you've got a frame within your
phone, you just [inaudible]
>>Trevor: which might not be the same thing
as the phone you're using.
>>Reto: We must go deeper.
Yeah, its' a good point.
'cause it looks great when I bring them up
full screen.
Like this actually looks pretty cool although
it is kind of inception-y but when you're
just looking at them in the carousel, it looks
kind of weird.
Cause you've just got like a bunch of phones
side by side.
Yeah.
I agree with that.
>>Trevor: yeah, those frames are more for
use on web pages.
Things like that.
Marketing material.
Not so, I mean, your play listing is marketing
material in a sense.
>>Romain: Absolutely.
>>Trevor: but not good to use them there.
>>Romain: No.
>>Reto: It's good to see as well it's been
translated into German, Japanese, Korean,
and Spanish.
And given that there's not actually a lot
of text, that seems like a really good way
of being able to create a better experience
for your users.
Make it more discoverable in Google play at
a relatively small cost.
And it's very well received looking at its
average reviews in market.
So well done.
Hopefully a few of those tips which we've
given you all will help to make your app even
better.
OK.
[banging noise]
>>Trevor: oooh, that was not good.
>>Reto: [inaudible] Get it all did it?
>>Trevor: Maybe it's alive.
>>Reto: hard to say.
>>Ian: Everything's alive.
>>Trevor: Right.
>>Reto: We're gonna assume we're alive.
Our confidence monitor has disappeared.
And Romain has dropped off the Hangout 'cause
that computer has taken a tumble.
But are we otherwise online Ian?
From what you can see?
>>Ian: Uh, you should be.
You should be.
>>Reto: Excellent.
Excellent.
>>Trevor: if you switch on the [h-tran] box
there.
I think we lost that signal.
Above the Mac.
>>Ian: Aaaah.
Yes.
OK.
>>Trevor: OK.
We'll let Ian sort all that out.
>>Reto: We will continue.
>>Ian: What do you guys wanna do next?
>>Reto: [laughs] We're gonna have a look at
GPS Test Plus I think.
[pause] OK.
So this is a GPS testing app.
So this is interesting and I'm gonna presume
that it's using some of the more advanced
geo, well, I guess GPS functions, a little
location based functions.
Which can actually get you a lot of information
about the way in which the location based
services are using satellite information to
be able to figure out where your location
is.
>>Trevor: Actually we're probably not going
to be able to see it in here with the ceiling
over our heads.
>>Reto: Yeah that's true.
But still, I mean, there's a window.
>>Trevor: Aaaaaaah.
It's asking a lot.
>>Reto: Alright.
Well, that's true.
Ok, so we've got zero in view, zero in use
right now.
So your accuracy is not useful.
>>Trevor: That's OK.
You can still see most of the app without
it.
>>Reto: Exactly.
I mean, the app itself we can look at.
So it's kind of an interesting display here.
It kind of reminds me of sort of an old school
sort of eight bit game type, you know, type,
look and feel.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I'll be honest, I'm not a
big fan of it though.
>>Reto: Yeah?
>>Trevor: Mostly, it feels out of place in
Android.
It's not holo.
If you flip through here, like you have this
>>Reto: haha.
>>Trevor: You know sort of fake LCD display.
But it doesn't really look like an LCD.
It looks like a computer generated.
I'd expect to see if you're gonna go for something
that's mimicking a real display add some,
add some gloss onto it.
Make it actually look real.
Go--
>>Reto: If you're gonna go, go all the way.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Use the digital look, go for the real look.
But in between in just looks sort of, MS Paintish,
to be honest.
>>Reto: No, that's absolutely true.
I, in fact, one of the first jobs I ever had
out of college was building software for an
industrial inspection company and because
all of the equipment that they usually use
is all sort of old school with the LCD displays
and everything.
And so I made the software to try and look
as much like that as possible.
And you'd find yourself getting into this
arms race where you want it to look just like
the real equipment.
And you do it first and it'll look like this,
everything's flat.
And you're like, oh, that's not quite right.
Because their stuff glows.
So how do I make this glow.
And then you start adding gradients to your
images and it just, it goes to a very bad
place.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Reto: And you end up spending a lot of time
trying to do these little things with canvases
and everything else to try and mimic something
which is done that way because it's cheaper
to do in hardware, not because it looks better.
>>Trevor: yeah.
And honestly the inverted way of doing things,
you know, we tend to not really try and mimic
real displays very often.
Real objects.
And that's just sort of, that's the style
we've chosen.
So.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Trevor: An app like this just feels out
of place on the system.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Trevor: I mean, ignoring the fact that we
have no action bar, I don't know why there's
no action bar.
We also have the menu button of shame.
But at least it has a menu.
>>Reto: It's not as shameful.
But.
>>Trevor: There's no reason that can't be
converted into an action bar.
But I think the app would look a lot nicer
with a splotch of holo on there.
>>Reto: I tend to agree.
>>Trevor: I think what the app developer is
trying to do, is if you go into settings you
can change the theme.
So I think they were trying to make it theme-able.
And you can choose like a night time view
or an amber view or a red view.
>>Reto: I gotcha.
I gotcha.
[inaudible]
>>Trevor: But you know, maybe that's not so
bad actually if you're out doors, stargazing,
you want a GPS 'cause you're going hiking.
Being able to set, alright, just through,
yeah.
Being able to set a, like a night view like
that--
>>Reto: Nice.
>>Trevor: is actually a pretty good idea.
>>Reto: Hm.
>>Trevor: But you could do something like
that and still stay true to holo, I think.
>>Reto: I think so.
I mean, this is, again, this is you know,
I spent all my time in a previous life working
on boats.
Where you had a lot of this equipment set
up.
And you do.
You have nighttime views.
As soon as the sun goes down you have this
much more muted thing so people don't destroy
their night vision while looking at the controls.
And I kind of like the idea of making that
sort of thing on something like that.
But part of me would say, well what is the
purpose of your app?
And so if it is to sort of work as a backup
or as an alternative to some of these GPS
systems while you're navigating, that first
I would say, it's probably of questionable
utility.
Because unless you're sitting on the roof
of your boat, then you're gonna have this
problem where you don't have any satellites
in view.
If it's just an aesthetic thing, you're just
really trying to mimic that style, because
that's what you're used to and you think that
your users will sort of appreciate that.
That's definitely a choice.
But I kind of agree with Trevor here, I think.
You can do that without making it look like
an old Atari game.
So you've got the same sort of layout.
The same sort of graphics.
Because the big graphics in these sorts of
features are definitely the right approach.
But you just wanna spend a little bit more
time to think about how you can use that same
layout to put on something which is much more
modern.
So mimicking a modern GPS rather than a GPS
which you would have seen in a computer game
in the '80s.
>>Trevor: And this actually brings up another
point here just as far as the number of options
in here.
I mean there's a lot of color schemes.
Which, you know, not necessarily a bad thing.
But just looking around the entire app, you
have a ton of settings.
Some of which are kind of redundant.
You have an option to choose imperial metric
units for your speedometer.
Imperial metric units for altitude.
You could condense all of those into just
one setting.
Do I want imperial or metric units?
Cause I can't think of very many cases where
I'd want my speed in one system and my altitude
in another.
>>Reto: That's true.
>>Trevor: Uh, there's some other things too,
and you can choose between, I think if you
go to this menu here, you can actually change
all these to gauges.
Which again has that same problem where it
looks sort of like an Atari game.
>>Reto: [laughs]
>>Trevor: It's just like, so many options
here.
And here it is.
And honestly, as a user, it's too much.
Because I'd never find them all.
>>Reto: Yeah, it makes it non discoverable.
It's like you almost, if you wanna be able
to choose between different gauges you may
wanna do that.
On the screen.
>>Trevor: And then even going to the options
on the bottom.
You know, there's this mode.
And this mode.
And then when you're in let's see here, there's
another mode here if you go to navigation,
[app dings]
And then you have this mode and this mode.
And then you have a hidden menu there.
>>Reto: [laughs] interesting.
>>Trevor: Which is, the navigation part is
very, it's a bit difficult to find especially
without textual labels on those buttons.
>>Reto: Yeah, so this is really interesting.
So I mean, it looks like this app is, does
a lot of stuff.
Like it's basically every gauge or dial you
would want.
Which has anything to do with location.
>>Trevor: Yeah, it's a very useful app.
Yeah.
>>Reto: Which I like.
And having, and I really wanna make a big
point of this.
Which is when we're discussing you know, changing
the UI to make it look less old school, I
really wanna emphasize that I don't think
that you should change the overall layout.
Like I love that it's big buttoned.
It's very graphical.
You know, everything is based around being
able to see it from a distance.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: I think that's a really good approach.
Yeah.
Like I say when it comes to the mimicking
the LCD stuff, like having been there I can
tell you that it's really not worthwhile and
the feedback that you get from most actual
users is "Yeah, that's really hard to read."
[laughs]
So it's' a lot of effort which may not entirely
be worth it.
So that may be something to keep in mind.
>>Romain: Hey.
Quick question.
Do you guys hear me right now?
>>Reto: We do.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: Welcome back.
>>Trevor: Welcome back, Romain.
>>Romain: OK.
I thought I'd.
>>Trevor: I don't think you can see us 'cause
our camera isn't glowing.
But.
>>Romain: Oh.
>>Trevor: We can't see you.
But we can hear you.
>>Romain: I have a few thoughts on this one.
[inaudible]
>>Trevor: Please.
Yeah.
>>Reto: Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
>>Romain: So one thing that immediately confused
me and I agree with that like the big dials
the big, I guess panels are awesome.
One thing that confused me a little bit was
about the interactions.
Basically you have these four panels at the
bottom.
This is on the home screen.
You have these four panels at the bottom.
>>Trevor: Yep.
>>Romain: and touching them basically switches
out the main display at the very top.
But it wasn't clear that those panels were
kind of like the top level hierarchy.
And then above those four panels, those four
buttons, was kind of the thing you're currently
viewing.
So I would try to use some sort of better
visual indication that at the bottom is kind
of like your primary control set.
And then at the very top is something that
is a member of that control set.
It's not currently visible because you know,
touching, they're kind of like tabs but the
current tab is not visible.
But somehow indicate that what you're viewing
at the top is one of the things that is you
know, in this other set of controls at the
bottom.
And then when you touch on, just, the numbers,
the one that has headings.
Speed and altitude.
You bring up another set of controls, where
basically speed, altitude and heading are
kind of a secondary set of quote unquote tabs.
And you could apply the same visual.
Maybe some sort of like arrow indicating that
you know, the top screen is a child of the
pre-- of the lower buttons.
Something like that.
I don't know if I'm explaining this very well
but I think it's just, the hierarchy isn't
clear immediately from the current presentation.
>>Reto: Yeah.
No, I totally agree.
It's sort of the idea of this being a toggle.
But it's not really a toggle.
Its' just swapping out whatever the currently
selected option is.
It was not obvious to me either.
And similarly as Trevor pointed out this,
there are basically two modes.
You've got a navigation mode which allows
you to, it works a lot like My Tracks in a
way.
It'll let you keep track of way points and
where those locations are.
Which is really really cool.
But then, and then there's GPS test, which
is another version.
And it's basically two apps within one app.
And it's not obvious like, when I'm sitting
here, I think, OK well I wanna go back to
the other mode, and so I hit back, and that
just exited the app.
Um, the right way to do it is to go back into
GPS test from here.
>>Trevor: I almost feel like GPS test might
not be the right name for this app.
>>Reto: It's so much more than that.
>>Trevor: They're just trying to build, honestly,
a GPS.
>>Reto: yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean that's the thing.
I can almost imagine where this has come from
like you know you fired up the Android SDK.
You see all this cool stuff you can do with
GPS.
And so you're gonna test all the GPS APIs
and then you create this app from it.
But I almost feel like it's time to move beyond
that in terms of the app name and try and
be a bit more descriptive of what it does.
And even in terms of your navigation here,
GPS test and navigation seem like two very
different functions.
They both use the GPS certainly, but in terms
of why you're gonna use them they're very
different.
[inaudible]
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Oooooo, but I can see the reason why.
I mean, having owned one of the really old
Garmin GPS units, this is basically the way
the UI worked.
You turned it on.
It gave you the GPS data screen.
Which showed you all the satellites and after
a while you get a lock and you switch over
to your waypoint navigation.
>>Reto: Sure.
Navigation.
>>Trevor: So you know, I can't say.
It really does feel like they're building
a proper GPS unit.
>>Reto: Sure.
>>Trevor: Not one of the fancy ones with mapping
and everything.
>>Reto: No.
>>Trevor: You know, just like an old
>>Reto: Garmin for your fire.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: That's interesting.
>>Trevor: I mean, I think that's a valid use.
But on the other hand I'm not sure if you're
using it like that, actually seeing that screen
is too useful.
I wasn't sure it was too useful on the old
GPS units either.
>>Reto: [chuckles]
>>Trevor: Really what you want to know is,
you know, you have an LED that says, is my
GPS locked?
[inaudible]
>>Reto: Do you have the lock?
>>Trevor: And then you could click on that
and have you pull up your whole GPS for you.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Trevor: So I mean, it really boils down
to what do you want this app to do?
Do you want it to be GPS test app?
Or do you want to take it to the next level.
I think you could.
You could actually just say "this is my GPS
utility app."
>>Reto: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And as far as that goes, that may then control
how you decide to structure your navigation.
Cause I think fundamentally even more important
than the graphics element, which I think,
I'm quite sure a lot of people are gonna disagree
with us and be like "No, I love the old school
stuff."
>>Trevor: Its' always subjective.
>>Reto: Exactly.
But I think much more important than that
is sorting out the navigation.
Make it much clearer.
Where you are in the app.
How to move to different parts of it.
And make everything work together.
And I think figuring out what is the key purpose.
I talked a little bit about this during my
IO session this year.
But, what is the focus.
What is the thing that you want people to
associate your app with?
Is it, oh yea, I wanna check to see what the
GPS quality is?
So I'm gonna use GPS test and fire it up and
see exactly how many satellites are in view
and what the accuracy is?
Or do you want it to be like OK, I'm going
for a hike or I'm going fishing and I wanna
be able to mark down the best fishing spots
and the best hiking trails?
And so I'm gonna use GPS test navigation to
do that.
Chances are it's gonna be one or the other.
It's what your users are using, or what your
direction to the app is.
And so I would try and find a way to focus
more on that, and make everything else sort
of more supportive of that.
Try and really get that focus as tight as
you can.
>>Romain: And one minor, one minor add on
to that, just aiding navigation and strategic--
[audio cuts out]
>>Trevor: Oh, I think we lost Romain.
>>Reto: We may have lost him, yeah.
>>Ian: Remember guys, when I was crawling
around on the floor?
>>Reto: We do remember it.
>>Ian: unplugging stuff?
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Ian: That's because somebody unplugged the
Chrome book and then used its original plug
to do something else.
>>Reto: [laughs] Handy.
>>Ian: so we have no Hangout.
That's just the way it is.
>>Reto: Sorry Romain, if you can still here
us.
Somewhere.
Anywhere.
>>Ian: He can't.
>>Reto: He can't.
No.
[laughter]
>>Trevor: We could have him dial in by phone.
>>Reto: Speak louder.
Phone!
Nice.
Yeah.
>>Trevor: Actually we could have him join
us on GTalk on that phone there.
We could switch back and forth between the
app and Romain.
No, that wouldn't work too well.
>>Reto: I think we're gonna stick with the
app for now.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: We'll have Romain join us again.
Hopefully next week.
We're gonna try and continue to keep him involved
in our Friday reviews even though he's all
the way in New York City.
>>Ian: Also gentlemen, just remember you have
about five minutes left.
>>Reto: Five minutes.
Excellent.
Alright, let's have a look.
So we're going to do a quick community service
announcement type talk on one of the apps.
Or a kind of app which is, which we get a
lot of nominations for.
And that is virus checkers.
>>Trevor: Oh yes.
>>Reto: so I can't see but I'm gonna assume
that you put the, put something on screen.
So we get a lot of nominations for virus checking
apps.
And one of the struggles we have is that if
we decide we wanna put it up and talk about
it is that it's then already been removed
from market or from Google play before we
get a chance to look at it.
So there is kind of a clue as to where I'm
going with this based on that.
And the struggle here is that a lot of the
times these apps are, their basically trying
to spread fud so it's a case of "Oh, its'
a computer type thing and I don't wanna get
a virus, don't wanna get malware so I better
download a virus checker to make sure that
that doesn't happen to me."
The problem is, well, I'm gonna turn that
around slightly.
The good news is that really isn't something
that you need.
So you don't need virus checkers for your
Android phones.
Most of the cases what these apps claim to
do isn't quite legit.
And so that's why a lot of these will disappear
from Google play.
Is because they're basically claiming to be
able to do something which they can't and
a lot of that is because that's already sandboxed.
That's really part of our security model is
that apps can't mess with other apps.
Which has the very positive side effect of
meaning that viruses are very very difficult
to create.
I mean, we certainly have had some small issues
with malware.
And there's processes in place to remove those.
But in terms of apps infecting other apps,
interfering with the way they work, isn't
really an issue.
The side effect of that is of course, by the
same token, having an app which is supposed
to go through and scan other apps and modify
the way they behave in the way that this virus
checker works, doesn't work either.
>>Trevor: Right.
So yeah.
There's really, you can't write a virus checker.
So if we see one, that's sort of immediately
raises a red flag for everyone on the team.
And we ask "What the heck is this app doing?"
and most of the time the answer is, it's lying
to the user.
>>Reto: [laughs] exactly.
And so even if it's not doing anything malicious
in and of itself, which often they aren't.
It's simply, its' claiming to do something
which you can't do.
And that definitely raises flags.
And to be honest a lot of the time we've seen
situations where apps like this are just trying
to prey on people's sort of preconceived notions
of what they need.
And they also, tend to have a pretty high
correlation of spam within the app description
and so on, itself.
So it's basically, for whatever reason, people
trying to get people to download this app
and you know, do advertising things around
that.
Now it's not always the case.
But that's certainly something which we've
found a lot of.
So we won't be reviewing any virus checker
apps, because as far as we're concerned, the
answer is, it does nothing.
So in case you're wondering why we skip past
them, in the future.
Now you know.
So.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
And I think there was a second part of that
app too, which is, I think it was like notification
spam checking.
>>Reto: Oh.
OK.
>>Trevor: which I think technically you could
do.
You can run through the whole package list
and search your package name. and you can't
look inside it but you could match against
known packages.
But honestly that's not even really needed
on Jellybean anymore.
Because you can just go and click on a notification
and find out which app it came from.
>>Reto: [inaudible] [laughs]
>>Trevor: So.
>>Reto: Exactly.
So it's something which we're definitely very
keen to try and make sure that the platform
is free of anything which is going to be annoying,
frustrating, malicious against users.
And we will try and find ways to do that within
the platform itself.
Because quite simply it's not something that
can be done effectively, or even at all in
most cases, by a third party app.
Alright, let's have a look at what else we've
got.
We have a bunch of notes apps.
I don't think we really have a lot of time
to look at them, so let's look at RunDouble
instead.
We'll have a look at, we'll do a Notes app
review next week.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: There's always a lot of notes apps
that we get for review.
So I think that's what we'll do next week.
Is just get like a whole collection of them.
We'll go through the moderator queue.
So if you have a notes app that you'd like
us to look at.
Probably a good opportunity to put it into
the Moderator queue.
And we'll run through like a bunch of them
and pick out the best and worst of each.
Alright.
So this is let's see.
What is the name of this app?
This is RunDouble.
[pause]
>>Trevor: Yeah, first comment, the UI sort
of hurts my eyes.
>>Reto: Yeah, it's a little bright.
Yeah.
It is extreme.
The other question I had about this and I'm
gonna go ahead and check here
>>Trevor: Also, menu buttons of shame.
>>Reto: Menu buttons of shame.
Yeah.
The ad as well.
So, no problem with having ad supported apps,
by any means.
But the concern here is more that it kinda
looks out of place.
Kinda like Ian, where he's hovering in front
of us.
You know, it really sort of, doesn't quite
work with the rest of the UI.
And everything feels kind of a little off
balance.
Perfect.
Thank you Ian.
We now can see ourselves again.
So I'm gonna have a look in the play store
because I have a suspicion.
I'm just gonna slide this back while I bring
up the right app.
OK.
C25K.
>>Trevor: Also that icon.
>>Reto: Yeah, it's a little unfortunate.
But what I'm almost more concerned with, so
what I'm not sure of here is whether or not
this app is officially sponsored by RunDouble
or this is an app which someone has built
to help support something by a third party.
>>Trevor: Yeah, it says it's by RunDouble
C25K.
>>Reto: Exactly.
That brings up a question mark for me.
And this is potentially, so again I don't
know in this particular case.
And I'll try and get in touch with the developer
and find out exactly.
But if it is a RunDouble app, then that's
great.
You know.
It's certainly something we'd like to see.
If it's not, so this is an app by someone
who has built something to support a third
party, you wanna be really cautious about
the way that you promote that.
Because there are rules in the Play store
about not creating apps and app descriptions
which make it seem as though your app is officially
affiliated with something that it isn't or
that it is an app that it isn't.
>>Trevor: Also more broadly speaking, there's
trademark laws as well.
You know.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Trevor: Which we can't comment on.
But it is something you need to be aware of.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Exactly.
So even leaving the legal side aside, if the
eval team looks at and we find out ok, it's
not by the RunDouble team, even if you, here
it isn't clear to me whether or not that's
the case.
And so you wanna make sure that you're really
clear to your users as to is this official.
Is this something that's in support of another
app.
And make sure of course that you have permission
from them to use their APIs or their resources
in that kind of a way.
So you know, we're really conscious about
trying to not confuse users and make sure
that they know exactly what's going on.
And here I'm a little confused.
So yes that's what I wanted to check.
So let's go back into the app.
Open it up.
So yeah the big thing here is that the UI
is, it's too bright.
Yellow is too much.
And then you've got the small icons with the
white text, again, sort of old school looking
icons which, no, they're reasonable resolution
but they're also look very vectory.
So yeah, I'd definitely work on that.
Like right now it's not particularly appealing
like it, just I'd make, wanna go away 'cause
it's' hurting too much.
Oh.
Yeah.
>>Trevor: and this thing is something I should
point out too.
>>Reto: Yeah, please do.
>>Trevor: So I think if, actually it's one
screen back.
So first off here, the "Change Plan" which
lets you, I think if you click something here,
it lets you, oh, it works now.
It tried to make me buy it earlier.
>>Reto: Oh, OK.
>>Trevor: I don't know why
>>Reto: Did you cave and buy it?
>>Trevor: No, I didn't.
So.
At least a few minutes ago when I tried to
do this.
Wow, I don't even know how to get back there.
Upgrade maybe?
Ah.
There we go.
So that's another thing that's confusing.
Like these menus are pretty much the same.
Why is it, and there's three ways to get to
this.
There, there, or there.
There really should just be one menu.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Trevor: But also when you buy these, your
most likely description is couch to 5 K and
I click buy.
And the description now does not say anything
similar, er Couch to 5 K weeks three to nine.
I guess it's' sort of similar but it doesn't
match exactly.
And that confused me for a second.
>>Reto: Yeah, it's not clear exactly what
you're getting.
I'm looking remaining weeks three to nine
which I guess implies that this is weeks one
to three?
And then this must be nine through something
else?
>>Trevor: No, no that's [inaudible]
>>Reto: No, that's all the same thing.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Reto: Uh.
>>Trevor: Yeah so basically my feedback there
is make sure your in-app descriptions if you're
doing in-app purchasing, or your descriptions
in your UI match what you give to market to
display in the purchase screens.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So I think what's going on here is that you
can do the Couch to 5 K as a free trial for
two weeks.
But if you wanna do the remaining three to
nine times week, then you need to do the purchase.
So that's, you know, if you read through it
in detail it can get to where its' trying
to get you to go.
But you definitely wanna make that as clear
as possible.
And you never--
>>Trevor: and that is a lot of text on one
screen.
>>Reto: And you never wanna be a pret case.
Like the real big advantage of in-app billing
is that it removes those barriers.
It's fewer clicks between "I want this" and
"I have this."
So you wanna make sure that that's as smooth
a path as possible.
As possible.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
I wanna say, like I said, get rid of the upgrade
menu and then the change plan button.
You know, have your purchase button right
there.
And then you can go and grade these out if
they're not available or if you're in trial
mode, you know.
>>Reto: Exactly, yeah.
>>Trevor: Yeah, but yeah,
>>Reto: Make it clear what you're getting
when you buy one
>>Trevor: there's too many ways you could
go and improve the purchase flow there.
And as an app developer that's good for you.
>>Reto: Yeah.
So OK, so I don't wanna spend too much more
time on this mainly because we're pretty much
out of time.
But the big, the big suggestion I would have
for you here is to basically take another
look at your UI.
Create something which is less busy.
Less bright.
And sort of less text, more pictures.
Really try, again, it's all about focus.
Try and figure out what is it that I would
get this app to do.
What are the actions that I want a user to
do once they start this.
And bring them to the forefront.
Everything else, you know some of it you may
wanna move into menus.
Or move further down the hierarchy.
Or just remove completely.
It's really just a case of figuring out, what
it is that you want me to do once I install
your app.
And try and drive me down that path as quickly
as possible.
>>Trevor: And blinding your users is usually
not what you wanna do.
>>Reto: No. not safe either, if they're running.
>>Trevor: Well, I mean, if that's what your
app is for.
If your app is called "Blind Me."
>>Reto: Blind me.
Yeah.
>>Trevor: [laughs] I'm being harsh.
It's yea, just this yellow on black
>>Reto: it's a bit much.
>>Trevor: It seems a bit much.
You know, again, like I was saying earlier,
try and make it blend in with the rest of
the system.
Take a look at the holo design guidelines.
I suspect you're trying to do some branding
here with the yellow and black thing.
Which is cool.
And there are ways to, and keep that motif
going, whilst still staying true to, how holo
is supposed to look and feel.
>>Reto: Mm. absolutely.
So we're out of time.
I wanna give Ian and Dan from the Friday Games
review a chance to setup.
So we're gonna sign off.
We will be back next week.
With a hopefully, Fred will be back again
next week as well.
And maybe Trevor will join us too.
And we're going to take a look at some note
taking apps.
So in the meantime we will bid you adieu.
Hopefully you will stick around and watch
the Friday games review with Ian and Dan.
And the mystery hat.
I'm not sure what the mystery hat is this
week.
But it's bound to be an exciting hat.
>>Trevor: And there's a mystery beer as well.
>>Reto: There's always a mystery beer.
That's very true.
>>Trevor: Ah.
But there's a special mystery beer.
>>Reto: Oh.
That's exciting.
>>Ian: That's right.
This time the beer is a mystery to Dan.
But I'll give you a preview 'cause I doubt
he's watching.
It's gonna be McKellers 1000 IBU.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Ian: We'll see how much of a hop-head he
truly is.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Reto: Now see, how can you turn that down?
So we expect that all of you guys will take
a quick bathroom break and we'll all be back
in ten minutes for the Friday Games review.
>>Trevor: Great.
See you everyone.
>>Reto: So.
Thank you for joining us.